[Música]
volvemos con ustedes para cinco minutos
con hoy hablaremos sobre la seguridad
nacional estadounidense con guillermo
pacheco profesor de asuntos de
geopolítica y relaciones internacionales
y consultor en temas de seguridad y
defensa internacional profesor gracias
por estar con nosotros para muchos
estadounidenses la violencia del 6 de
enero ha representado un punto de
inflexión en la política del país cuáles
son las repercusiones justamente hoy en
el día de la investidura del nuevo
presidente de eeuu buenos dias gusto
saludarte de un privilegio estar con
todos los televidentes de france presse
mirá que definitivamente el impacto ha
sido en que hemos estado viendo una
ciudad de washington dice así que hace
día parece un fortín militar y los
números lo revelan los números revelan
la cantidad de efectivos de la guardia
nacional del fbi y de las policías de
todas las agencias de seguridad de los
eeuu entonces estamos bien viendo algo
inusual desde mi punto de vista un
poquito exagerado en relación a lo que
pudo haberse dado en este día 20 de
enero que es un día de
fortalecimiento democrático por decirlo
así en los eeuu cree que esta
exageración en seguridad que usted
identifica sea ya un panorama normal
ante las amenazas que generan los grupos
armados de extrema derecha y la división
que hay en eeuu este panorama de
militarización podría ser la nueva
normalidad en el gobierno de joe biden
bueno si tú lo mencionas claro
pues podría ser una nueva normalidad
respecto a esta amenaza no sé qué tanta
puede hacer una amenaza creo yo que los
números como te mencionaba lo dice
cuando obama toma su primera posesión se
usaron más o menos 10.000 miembros de la
guardia nacional y tocan 5.000 en su
segundo mandato el presidente de trump
se utiliza mucho milk y ahora se estaban
utilizando 25.000 creo que la diferencia
es abismal entonces me imagino que esto
pudiera ser como parte de los primeros
meses hasta que se normalicen esta
situación que yo creo que será
normalizada prontamente debido a que
estos estas amenazas bajarán bastante
profesor pese a haber exacerbado las
divisiones en eeuu poco antes de
terminar su presidencia de donald trump
deseo éxito a joe biden e intentó
proyectar una imagen de unidad en su
despedida pero también dejó una semilla
dijo que lo que él convenció no se acaba
y que es el inicio de un nuevo
movimiento qué forma podría adoptar este
movimiento profesor
mira yo pienso que tiene dos dos caminos
uno es fortalecerse el partido
republicano no podemos echar de menos
que sacó más de 70 millones de votos el
presidente trump entonces 70 millones de
votos en los eeuu no son nada
despreciables los republicanos pueden
fortalecer esa parte bajando un poco
este esta dialéctica que se utilizó y
que lee y que mediáticamente se le
atribuyó al presidente trump y el
segundo es que el presidente trump pueda
generar una tercera opción además de los
republicanos y los demócratas y repito
son 70 millones de votos que no son nada
despreciables para una visión política
que se pueda tener aquí en los eeuu en
el futuro vamos ahora con el mejor
escenario y el peor en términos de
seguridad nacional una guerra civil y
atentados violentos cuál es el mejor y
el peor escenario en términos de
seguridad nacional para el gobierno de
job aire
mira el empecemos por el por el peor
escenario el peor escenario es que pueda
incluso hasta exacerbarse y poder llegar
a una a un enfrentamiento civil indio
donde vivió una guerra civil pero si un
enfrentamiento civil hubo presencia en
los 50 estados en los capítulos de los
50 estados y haces hace 3 días
entonces se puede dar una un
exacerbamiento que pueda llevar a un
enfrentamiento civil bastante grande
vuelvo y repito no son pocos los
seguidores que deja el presidente trump
y por eso es que llama a esta visión de
paz y el segundo es que en pocos meses
se pueda generar un mensaje de parte del
presidente bai ling que bajen los ánimos
que abra desde esta visión que ellos
presentan de inclusividad y que ellos la
reflejen justamente aceptando también a
estas a estos grupos y no haciéndolos a
un lado porque se los hacen a un lado
creo que ahí sí puede generarse este
peor escenario
para llegar a un mejor escenario con 20
segundos nos queda nada más profesor que
nos identifica
para llegar al mejor escenario creo que
lo que se tiene que generar son estas
medidas de confianza mutua
en seguridad se utiliza esto medida de
confianza mutua y le quedan las manos al
presidente va a intentar todo su equipo
de seguridad y de política y de todos
los demás del gobierno poder generar
unas medidas de seguridad
mundial que le permita el generar la
confianza gracias guillermo pacheco por
esta comunicación y gracias a ustedes
por su compañía siguen france24
[Música]